[Musique]
les césar du meilleur espoir féminin est
attribué à camélia jordana dans le
brillant
d'octobre en place a connu pour ses
dérapages accepte de préparer un
concours d'éloquence pour se racheter
une conduite
on a évidemment déclare tom chanteuse
dans l'émission nouvelle star en 2009 et
elle a fait ses débuts au cinéma dans la
stratégie de la puce est en 2013 elle
était aussi en 2017 à la fiche de
chercher la femme de souabe a dit il va
tomber bientôt roy disney est le premier
long métrage de la journaliste caroline
fourest avec notamment deux shifts et
tahar hani esther garrel ou encore amira
casar
[Musique]
merci bonsoir tout le monde c'est vrai
que c'est très émouvant d'être devant
vous tous j'ai tenté d'écrire quelque
chose parce que je me suis dit que le
film du coup dans lequel j'ai joué parlé
quand même d'éloquence je faisais que
c'était assez à propos et puis en fait
j'ai pas réussi
j'aimerais remercier yvan attal pour sa
tendresse son amour sa bienveillance son
regard et son exigence daniel auteuil
c'était dingue
merci vraiment c'était bon j'aimerais
remercier dimitri rassam et benjamin
elalouf les producteurs du film merci
aussi pour votre présence et votre
confiance
mon agent et 10 fécamp pour ta passion
et ta présence
sa légèreté merci merci à l'académie du
coup c'est fou vous avez voté pour moi
gentil je voudrais simplement dire un
petit mot quand même bîmes surveille la
salle à j'ai été ravi de la rencontre et
de de raconter son histoire et
j'aimerais dire à toutes les tailles la
sallaz et à tous les nail aux
que en fait vraiment vraiment quand on
se donne les moyens de faire les choses
et qu'on lâche pas se passe des trucs
j'étais pas sensé pleurer du tout
j'aimerais juste dire
je sais que normalement fait pas à la
famille tout ça juste merci à ma mère
pour sa force qui a dû arrêter d'aller à
l'école malgré son amour pour les mots
et grâce à elle du coup je les ai
raconté là dedans et ça donne ça merci
infiniment bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]